[music]
>> Rule number one, which is the most
important
rule
of the complete Dawah training program
is
100% attendance
for the complete international Dawah
training program is compulsory.
Point number two,
not a single day
from the 33 days training program can be
missed.
Point number three,
on each day not a single session can be
missed.
Point number two and three are
specifying
and giving more details of point number
one.
If I say 100% attendance is compulsory,
maybe someone will come on the last half
hour and say I was present on that day.
So, to be crystal clear
and not to leave any doubt
in the mind of any participants,
point number two and three specify that.
And
point number four, five, six, seven give
further details.
Point number four says, all participants
should reach the venue, that is the
famous studio, latest by 7:25.
You can be in this auditorium by 7:50.
The reason we're calling you earlier,
which may have been told to you
yesterday in the orientation session,
that
normally
the audience doesn't do
makeup in a general gathering,
but because inshallah
some of you are already Dawahs, some of
you would be future Dawahs,
and when you'll be coming on the stage,
we want you to look professionals.
And you know, certain times you do
things
which you don't like.
I personally don't like the makeup.
But if you're doing the things you don't
like
for the cause of Islam, Allah rewards
you double.
Some of you may like makeup, so you get
to get a reward, you get single reward.
If you like the makeup and you do it,
you get single reward. If you don't like
the makeup and you do it for the cause
of Allah, you get double reward.
I personally don't like makeup.
Personally, I hate it.
You'll never find me except when I'm
facing the camera.
And if
it's going to reach
millions of people and if it's going to
make an effect in conveying the message.
Which we shall deal
inshallah in that particular session.
So, we're calling you a bit early so
that you can even put the makeup on. And
daily
as is mentioned in the daily schedule,
it will start sharp inshallah at 8:00.
Did you receive the daily schedule?
It's there with you. It starts at 8:00
and officially
ends at 6:30 officially.
There's also an official ending.
It can extend till 8:00. There are times
when we have debating sessions. It will
go on even till 10:00, 10:30, 11:00.
There are days which are already
scheduled. So, if it's scheduled for
10:00, it may end at 12:00.
Point number five. Not a single
participant is expected to come late on
any of the 33 days.
Point number six. Even during each
session
the participants should be seated in
their respective seats at the scheduled
time or at the time instructed by the
trainer before the break. There may be
times
when the session may extend.
And suppose the normal break is at
10:15, maybe the tea break.
It may extend for about half an hour.
So, but naturally the next session, the
break will not be reduced inshallah most
of the time. Sometimes it may have to be
reduced.
But most of the time we will not reduce
the break
whether it's the break for lunch or the
two tea breaks that we have.
So, the instructor will tell you when to
come back in time and see to it that
you're on time, yeah?
>> In
while the session is on, no one should
have the need to leave the auditorium.
See to it that you're seated here.
Whatever requirement is there, you
fulfill during the breaks.
Does anyone have any questions regarding
the first seven points?
The first seven points are mainly
regarding attendance only.
And your presence
that we want you to be present 100%
with mind, body, and soul.
This is only talking about the body.
These seven points are talking about the
body, but I would want that all of you
should be present with
mind, body, and soul.
Any questions?
Point number eight.
That please do not walk on the center
aisle. Use only the left or right side
aisle irrespective of where you're
seated. If you have to come up on the
stage
or when you're coming to give a
presentation on the stage,
please see to it that don't walk
from the center aisle. So, those who are
sitting on the left of the stage
should
move towards the left and come to the
stairs on the left side. Those who are
sitting on the right of the stage,
that's
while you're facing me, see to it that
you step on right side
and come to the stage which is right
side of the stage.
I would request especially those people
who are sitting from brother Muhammad
Fadli and Farik and Arsh,
when you get off, since you're sitting
on the right side, you move towards the
right side of your chair. And Ibrahim
and Muhammad Fadli, when you move,
you step towards the left. Again, the
reason is we don't want you to block the
camera. We don't want your back to come
to the camera. We want your face to come
to the camera.
>> [snorts]
>> Is it clear?
Point number nine.
Notes would be given
for more than 80% of the sessions taken.
Some notes
would be in detail
mentioning almost everything what is
spoken on the stage,
but most of the notes would be in point
form.
Thus, you would not be concentrating on
making notes of the session, but rather
paying attention to the matter of the
session and grasping it and retaining
it.
However, in point form notes,
you can note some of the examples
and explanations
given in brief.
Most of the time whenever we take any
session, unless it's your presentation.
If it's a session where the participants
are presenting, it's different, but any
instructor that comes on the stage,
myself or my colleagues, whenever they
come, more than 80% of the time, they'll
be giving you notes.
If it's a point form note like the one
you have received, it will be given to
you before the session starts.
So, if you get a note
of the session
before the session starts,
you realize it is a
point form note.
If you get a note after the session
is completed, it's a complete text.
So, the difference between the notes.
So, most of the notes would be point
form notes like the one that is given to
you just now
in this session, rules and regulations
of the International Dawah Training
Program. Some of the notes, if it's a
lecture,
it will be given to you later on, which
will be the complete text of the speech.
If you want to ask any questions,
please raise your hand.
Only after the instructor points to the
questioner,
the mic will be handed over
to you by the assistant.
Please ask the question only after
receiving the mic.
If you want to ask a question,
if the instructor points to you,
then only
will the mic assistant come and deliver
the mic to you.
The microphone will be switched on
before we hand it to you.
Please do not press any button on the
microphone unless instructed to.
It's a very common practice that
whenever microphones are given
and the people they get they start
fidgeting. It may not be their fault, it
will be the fault of the organizer that
they don't
maybe give it to you in the right
position.
So, if the mic is switched on and you
put it off and you try speaking
So, most of the time inshallah
when the mic will be handed to you it
will be switched on.
While asking the question please hold
the mic
close to your mouth and speak directly
into the microphone.
Point number 13.
If the session is a talk
and not a point-based explanation
in which point form notes would be given
before the session starts
please do not interrupt the talk.
At the end of the talk, there will be a
question and answer session
for few minutes. That means
if it's a lecture given to you
which is not a point form
lecture
see to it that you don't interrupt the
instructor.
The talk may be for half an hour
maybe for 45 minutes, maybe for 1 hour.
In this situation
there'll always be some time left for
the question answer session.
It may be mentioned in the schedule, it
may not be mentioned.
It may be mentioned, it may not be
mentioned. But, always every session
will have a question answer time.
Point number 14. If point form notes are
given to you when it's a session
where description is given of each point
after every few points the instructor
will give opportunity for you to ask
questions.
So, if it's a point form note
you you might have observed that when
the first portion first seven points
were over
talking about attendance, I asked
does anyone have any questions? And no
one had alhamdulillah.
And I believe all of you would be
attending
all the days all the sessions, every
minute of the training inshallah.
During question answer session
only ask
the specific questions related to the
topic of that session
and not general questions on Islam and
comparative religion or how to do dawa.
When you're asking questions ask
questions related to that topic only.
Point number 16.
If you want to ask a specific question
on a particular religion
please note down
in your notepad
and ask it on the day and session
related to that subject. The 33-day
schedule mentioning the theme of the day
is given to you also for this purpose.
The reason we've given you all the 33
days of the training program
you know, some people may have certain
question on Christianity.
Oh, Christianity is on day so and so.
Day one, day two, day three. Three days
I have on Christianity. So, if you have
any questions, note it down.
While we are speaking about objectives
and if someone asked me that how can you
prove Jesus is not God?
Peace be upon him. So, now
we do already session on that which is a
detailed talk over half an hour
is Jesus God.
So, the instructor will not be able to
do justice.
And if he spends half an hour
on a question which is not related to
the topic
you will be losing the points which are
important for the topic. So, please see
to it that questions specifically
on the topic of the session should be
asked.
Any other question on comparative
religion
it should be asked on the specific day.
La ilaha illallah.
>> [music]
[music]